chiedo a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa dj ed oggi dopo non
so quanti miliardi di secoli sono
tornati su è più forse c'erano i
dinosauri tutti motorie registrata non
lo so non mi ricordo neanche più come si
gioca ma che giura perché c'è già chi si
sta tallinn quando una ragazza allora no
ma tu non puoi rubarmi la donna così
perché 61 lurida paltracca che non sei
altro è la mia donna non è la mia
[ __ ] donna non puoi permetterti di
farle questo romanzo di merda ma anche
pistola è questa ragazzi come come primo
livello non aveva una minchia di senso
ma meglio così jetpack cool kids è che
cazzo è stato ok mi piace rossa farò la
mia testa mi dov'è andato a finire io
rega questo non lo capivo che cazzo 16
fallo c'è ma è normale guidare un
jetpack così l'inter non sei normale le
capre che secondo me non lo è tantissimo
infatti vai vai vai vai vai bye bye bye
bye bye
gli script school però che su questo già
dal titolo mi ha preso tantissimo e non
puoi lasciare la scuola torna dietro
cava anch'io volevo un papa che mi
veniva a prendere con la bici in classe
che mi portava a casa ci sarebbe stato
stupendo ora che ci pensa però non trovo
il senso ha tutto questo richiama che
cazzo tutte quante grossa sotto alla
madonna
scusate non era mia intenzione mi scusi
buona donna sommetta don sulla testa non
so se norma ok perfetto tutti debitori e
rosso che pesi 380 kg e che un po
difficile ma ti devi togliere dai
[ __ ] perfetto o giallo prof come
vanno non ci si siede così sulla carta
per per favore si metta dritto si metta
dritto riga eva aveva [ __ ] a loro se
non capisce quello che le dico mi
dispiace elementi per favore se rimanete
seduti ho mai usato spararmi puttanata
mi fermerete mai per grifo d'oro era
[ __ ] forza in palestra
ok bravo ma ma che tricot fatto matrix
mi fa una pippa
lui si va fuori di qua perfetto serie
bello raga finalmente possa essere un
bambino felice perché altro che ho 40
anni il possible 87 93 che calzolari
bello che mettono la precisione
dell'impossibilità come se fosse
veramente impossibile per me ok forse un
pochettino ma non più di tanto perché
posso fare così
frena l'itcg cerca il calcio di
punizione ma [ __ ] gli hunger games dei
casi sono gli hunger games scrivendo il
suo signore plays ok anche su youtube
sono già iniziati i ragazzi la possiamo
fare capi vinceremo noi vinceremo e uk
ragazzi io che già morto amico mia
famiglia tra da infilza chiunque
ok questo caso bravo così cinque
partecipanti rimanenti ragazza posso
fare mi viene da vomitare perché mi
viene da vomitare che è successo su così
tentano di battermi lega non ce la
faranno mai
abbiamo vincitore se ho vinto cosa morto
sono sono morto alla fine non scherzate
ma ciò significa che ha vinto ma come
cazzo è possibile world 32 fix che
cazaux è messo a cantare mi dispiace ma
microfono lo prendo io grazie mille
ragazzi chi vuole microfono sui bei lo
vendo ragazzi l'ultimo non ce la farò
mai ma cipro
ok sì se si una sega lo infilata nel ca
pranzi alla threats dai sì eccolo lì per
te assaggia questa lurida stronza human
centipede scegli tu di nesta me lo stai
chiedendo insomma 10 quasi
ragazzi non è possibile che mi sei
mancato così poi si dai
che storia né possibile ho vinto verrà
ho vinto veramente così state scherzando
michele questo passo dalla storia del
target boltro odio questo modo mica
bellissimo ragazzi non sa se mamma pam
pam pam mica non ho preso una eccolo
eccolo mila di merda si come no non è
possibile
no no ma com'è che non ci posso credere
ma mio dio lo sto prendendo una mezz'ora
no non ci posso credere legale non ci
posso veramente crei [ __ ]
ho avuto paura per un attimo è tanta
ragazzina mi intendo tanto di macchine
però questa che cosa cazzo sarebbero già
ma cos'è stallo e yo yo conquistano la
ciao steve
come stai tutto a posto senti mettiti
comodo che ti che andiamo a casa
perfetto ricadeva che un paniere estiva
a casa che mi ha chiesto siamo già
arrivati
enter the box to word music bar vai con
indiana riga ciò posso che quest'anno
questo è facile ma [ __ ]
sì sì ok briga
no non c era entrata era entrato era
entrato sì io rimarrò così per il resto
del livello che ho paura di ficcare un
tasto che finisco 18 ma ci devo provare
lega no no quella è la parte sbagliata
da una parte sbagliata merda lo sapevo
se mi richiede spinta michele spinta
indiana indiana signore e signori
indiana è lui il nuovo idolo è lui il
nuovo [ __ ] e idolo di tutti non
toccare melone io non so che cosa possa
avere di strano quel melone pro mia mia
mi hanno detto di non toccarlo e io
ovviamente lo vado torneo per tutti lega
va bè ragazzi prima di concludere volevo
proprio un paio di miei livelli visto
che da un secolo che non faccio nemmeno
quelli fa vj spyphone dai facciamo
questo vediamo se riesco a fare qualcosa
di decente almeno qui è una cosa è mio
vado e il salto è sempre nella madonna
ma quello che manca e che non riesco a
fare un pezzo di m
migliaia
[ __ ] dai sì ok
stavolta sì stavolta sì stavolta si
giochi o precisione fa vincere così
chiama solo fa vj però preso un casino
di botti non si sa come mai valigia in
piscina
favi jazz in piscina tuffate ok mi devo
fidare di stato sono è lo sapevo avresti
dovuto controllare se c'era l'acqua ma
questo siete simpatici vj per curvi due
ragazzi faccio l'ultimo perché voglio
vedere allora fate armani jeans mitch
livello potremo sposarci e bella cosa
grazie di avermi dato questa notizia
splendida ma non ho finito il livello io
non vorrei finire a prescindere perché
poi quello che spicca però va bene lo sa
ho trovato una scarpa di qualcuno a noi
il mio piede
si ok non so come ho fatto a fare
l'ultimo salto ma ce l'ho fatta super
salto dove qui già fatta già fatta a
riga è difficilissimo sto livello sì sì
michele satta grazie per aver giocato
non ci sposeremo perché non l'ho finito
perché non abbassa la scritta vittoria
ma va bene uguale cercherò di fare il
prossimo il prima possibile ragazzi
comunque parola servillo è piaciuto
l'estate come al solito un commento mi
piace anche a progetti facebook che come
ogni video tratte nella descrizione deve
essere crisi iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo
al prossimo vitobello ragazzi